-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night,"
and we hope you're doing well
tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
After House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy denied reports
that he had planned to ask
former President Trump to resign
in the wake of the capitol
attack, "The New York Times"
released audio of McCarthy
telling colleagues he was going
to talk to Trump
about stepping down.
Alright, well, you know,
I'm sure he wouldn't lie.
It was probably just a
misunderstanding. Let's hear it.
-Oh, alright, well,
that's pretty damning.
[ Laughter ]
That'd be like the
"Encanto" family saying
"We always talk about Bruno."
[ Laughter ]
After new audio revealed that
House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy was planning to
urge former President Trump
to resign after
the capitol attack,
Trump said that he thinks it was
"A big compliment."
So we should just add "resign"
to the list of the words
he doesn't know?
[ Laughter ]
"Mr. President,
you need to resign."
[Imitating Trump] "Thank you,
I have been working out."
[ Laughter ]
[Normally] Politico published
photographs on Friday
that appear to show Republican
Congressman Madison Cawthorn
wearing lingerie at a party.
And I would say this is
embarrassing for him,
except he looks amazing.
[ Laughter ]
Plus, I don't think this story
will last,
because if you Google "Madison"
and "lingerie,"
this isn't even on
the first 12 pages.
[ Laughter ]
I was told!
Baze, you got to tell her you
wrote that joke, Baze.
If she calls the office, Baze,
you got to take credit for it.
While speaking in Seattle on
Friday to commemorate Earth Day,
President Biden said that the
Republican Party has changed
and added "This ain't your
father's Republican Party."
Yes. And it certainly isn't
your father's Republican Party,
because they nominated Lincoln.
[ Laughter ]
During his -- some people have
been critical, saying,
"You got to stop making jokes
about how Biden's
an older gentleman."
So from now on,
if you're watching the show,
we're going to say he's 32.
[ Laughter ]
Problem a-solved.
During his rally in Ohio
over the weekend,
former President Trump appeared
to see himself
on one of the screens and said,
"What a handsome president."
Here, I think
we have some footage.
-Pretty bird.
Pretty bird.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-At the same rally,
former President Trump said
that he didn't like being called
stupid,
so he asked then White House
doctor Ronny Jackson
to give him a test to prove
his intelligence.
And this is cool --
the other side had a menu.
[ Laughter ]
Trump also said that
water pressure regulations
cause problems with the,
"third element of a bathroom,
so people have to flush toilets
up to 10 times."
Of course, when Trump says
he has to go number three,
it means he's flushing
classified documents.
[ Laughter ]
[Imitating Trump]
"Mel, don't go in there!"
[ Laughter ]
"Do not --
A lot of call logs, Mel.
'Cause I don't know how
the shredder works.
We've had this conversation."
[ Laughter ]
[Normally] A city in Michigan
yesterday appointed
a cat named Jinx as the mayor
for a day.
It was all fun and games until
Jinx signed an executive order
implementing
a nightly fireworks show.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, we could have gotten
a dog that looked more
like a dickhead.
That is --
And finally, firefighters in
Washington State last week
rescued a woman after she fell
headfirst into an outhouse
toilet trying to retrieve her
cellphone, which is crazy,
because it was an Android.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!